FRANK: Steve?
Linda?
LINDA: Hi.
FRANK: How you doing?
I'm Frank.
Hey, I'm Mike.
Nice to meet you.
Hello.
LINDA: Trying to
clean up a little bit.
FRANK: Woo!
It looks like you guys
are packed in here.
LINDA: Yeah we are.
MIKE: So she was saying that
there was three generations--
Yeah.
My grandfather--
MIKE: --of stuff in the house.
--and then my dad
who was the big--
FRANK: A big collector?
MIKE: He was the one that
was most responsible?
If you could call
it a collection.
MIKE: OK.
The collecting in
our family is pretty
much contagious throughout.
Everybody caught the bug.
Great granddad, granddad,
mom and dad, me, my son.
So, yeah, it just
goes on and on.
That's some of the stuff that
we're kind of interested in.
I mean--
Yeah, I think we'll
have most of that.
So you guys-- we
heard that nobody's been
here like for 20 years.
- That's correct.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
MIKE: What made y'all all of
a sudden just start thinking,
hey?
STEVE: Time to
start cleaning up.
LINDA: My husband
said, Linda, we can't
leave a mess like we've had.
She's trying not to
leave a mess for me.
MIKE: Oh, OK.
So you collect too?
- I do.
And you can come see
me in about 20 years
and look at my collection.
MIKE: Yeah.
STEVE: If you think
this is something,
walk over here and look at this.
FRANK: What we got?
Wow.
Yeah.
MIKE: Oh my gosh.
LINDA: This is a lot of my
junk until you get back there,
and that's my grandfather's.
MIKE: Oh your grandfather's
stuff is in here too?
OK.
FRANK: I can see something
right now I'm interested in.
LINDA: What's that?
FRANK: What about
these Maytag motors?
These would of went
in washing machines.
STEVE: All right.
FRANK: And these were
some of the first
gasoline-powered appliances.
A lot like a hit and miss motor.
You know, they used to run.
They were the heart of the farm.
STEVE: Right.
FRANK: I mean they
ran everything.
Maytag Motors were made
for washing machines.
Most the time I
step right over 'em.
I don't care about 'em.
But these are twin cylinders.
They're opposed motors,
so not locked up.
They're a little harder to find.
STEVE: That's crazy that
things ran on gas back then.
FRANK: Well this
was the very first--
very first thing that ran on gas
as far as appliances and stuff.
STEVE: OK.
FRANK: They don't command
a lot of money, you know.
There's hit and miss
shows and stuff.
They bring a little
bit more money.
But on both of 'em, $125?
How about $150
for both of 'em?
That's two of 'em.
FRANK: Yeah, I know.
I mean, they obviously
don't run, you know.
True.
But if you give me $150
we'll give you a better
deal on something else.
We'll get along fine.
- We'll get along?
OK.
I want to get along fine.
I've got a lot of
stuff to look through.
- Yeah.
- All right.
- A lot of stuff.
- Very good.
STEVE: Well, dig in.
These were toys that
you played with Linda?
Yes.
Sure did.
Do you remember Jumbo,
blowing the bubbles?
LINDA: Oh yeah.
I loved that.
I got that about 1958, '59.
FRANK: Yeah.
I got a couple of these
and they are so cool.
They're battery-operated.
They have a little cup.
You put a little bit of
dish-washing soap in it.
It bends down, picks it up, and
then it blows air through it,
which makes a bubble come out.
Problem with battery-operated
toys, once they set,
they don't work.
- Right.
The box is a little--
it is what it is.
LINDA: Yeah.
What would you have
to have for this?
Oh, $30.
Right on the button.
See, we're thinking
the same now.
- OK.
- We're getting there.
All right.
STEVE: She's treating you right.
We're talking the
same language now.
FRANK: You got it.
Bubbles-- I used to love
to play with that thing.
STEVE: I was kind of
surprised she sold that.
But--
Surprise, surprise.
Yeah, it's a good thing.